JEN: This week we're
talking about BigQuery, ML,
and the Speed Read.
I'm Jen, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
BigQuery's been adding so
many capabilities lately,
it can be hard to keep up.
Thankfully, this
post captures it all.
From a super-sized
streaming quota
to built-in support for
Federated Cloud SQL Queries,
find out what's new in BigQuery
and how you can try these out
for yourself.
Have you seen
what's possible when
you combine the best of
BigQuery and Cloud AI Platform?
A great place to start is
ML forecasting-- a business
critical challenge when
dealing with time series data.
With this code-packed
guide, you'll
see how the
framework in BigQuery
can be used to help with
all sorts of predictions.
While you're at it,
see how BigQuery
can help you create models
for one more difficult task--
patent landscaping.
At Google, we're
sharing a methodology
that uses Python and
BigQuery to allow
you to easily access patent
data and generate automated
landscapes.
Read our guide, then
grab the code from GitHub
and start mapping your own.
Looking for a quicker way to
keep up with hot cloud topics?
The "Google Cloud
Blog" is the new home
for the "Speed Read" by
Quentin Hardy, a "New York
Times" editor with decades of
experience observing the tech
sector.
Quentin believes
we have a tendency
to over-complicate
technological change,
and he's here to put
things into perspective.
Check out the "Speed Read" and
stay tuned to the "Google Cloud
Blog" for more posts.
If you want to read
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.